[Music]
most psychologists agree the best way to
have somebody increase empathy is to
engage in something called
perspective-taking
imagining that you're someone else
trying to cognitively and emotionally
understand some event from their
perspective it's hard to do that often
we don't have the facts meaning I don't
know what's going on through your mind I
don't have an experience of what it's
like to be you and it's also very
effortful it's hard to actually imagine
what it's like to be someone else and in
fact when it comes to empathy we're
often thinking about unpleasant things
for example what it's like to be
homeless and the brain doesn't want to
go there so VR is a really neat tool
because it takes that cognitive effort
out it make increases accuracy so you're
not operating on stereotypes you may
have in your mind but you can actually
experience the life of someone else as
that person lives since 2003 I've been
running experiments that take a person
puts her in virtual reality and gives
her an experience that you couldn't have
in the real world this could be being in
a different place or could actually be
becoming a different person so the first
study we ran was about ageism and we
took college-age students and they
walked up to a virtual mirror and the
reason we have a virtual mirror is to
show the person they're they've become
different via a process called body
transfer this is a neuroscientific
process where if you move your physical
body and you have an avatar that moves
what's called synchronously that means
at the same time that you move your arm
you see it's our move and you see that
in a mirror as well in the first person
over time the part of the brain that
contains the schema for the self expands
and includes this external
representation as part of the body so by
using a virtual mirror and showing
somebody moving with the mirror you can
literally feel like you've become
someone else you can be a different
gender a different age you can become
disabled you can have a different skin
color and our first study took college
aid students we had them become older
about 60 to 70 years old
we then networked a second person into
virtual reality and there is a
conversation between the two over time
the conversation turned to stereotypical
concepts about being older so perhaps
you didn't have
the memory and these stereotypes were
activated in the conversation so while
wearing the body of someone else who's
an older person I felt discrimination
firsthand as a subject and what we
showed in that first study published in
2005 was that subjects who had gone
through this treatment became less
ageist when they came out for example if
you asked them to list words about the
elderly they were less likely to list
words that were stereotypical since that
first study we've run dozens of studies
we've looked at empathy in terms of
becoming a different race becoming
different gender even becoming a
different species if you become a cow
how does that make you think about
animals and what our research has shown
is the Vieira's not a magic tool doesn't
work every single time but in general
across all of our studies VR tends to
outperform control conditions for
example imagining or someone else by a
role playing or reading about case
studies this experience of walking a
mile in someone's shoes it tends to be
more effective at causing empathy and
behavior change towards others at the
2018 Tribeca Film Festival we're gonna
premiere a piece called thousand cut
journey I'm working with Courtney
Cogburn she's a professor at Columbia
and she studies implicit bias and
black/white racism the piece is designed
to show how people of color do not
experience racism once or twice in their
lives it's it's a process they go
through pretty much every day and so
this piece is you start out as an
elementary school child and you're in a
classroom you then become a teenager and
you're interacting with police officers
you then become an adult is going on a
job interview and what you experience
while wearing the body of a black male
is implicit bias that happens repeatedly
and over time and so that's a piece
that's going to premiere in April and
what we're currently doing is running
experiments to test to see if it changes
attitudes and what aspects of the
experience are most effective at
changing those attitudes
[Music]